but I don't know who it is I don't know
I know what it is it must be nice what's
up guys I'm Jeff hi I'm Troy hi I'm aja
hi I'm destiny and today we're playing
trivia I know a lot of random stuff so I
feel like I'll be alright I'm more of a
faces person than the actual name so
like I'm really hoping the multiple
choices will help me out in this
situation but we'll see well I'm
actually more of a name person than face
I am NOT a numbers person so if you
throw some dates at me I'm so sorry in
advance I think Troy is gonna yeah
honestly I think I'm a sleeper so I'm
gonna go a me money on myself
I think I'm gonna win all right what's
your surprising something surprising to
myself
who made history by becoming the first
black president of the United States
Hey shirley chisholm be Barack Obama see
ben Carson or D Jessie J I'm ready be
Barack Obama Kamala Harris rolling w
Blanche capers I'm gonna go for that see
you know when you guess it's always see
[Music]
[Music]
I'm so glad you got that right
[Music]
Nichelle Nichols is on the board I'm
gonna go see yes and I mean see let's
say hey and go with D dry-cleaning
what's my like that's my winning pose
I can't let me get my winning pose
at just 6 years old
this little girl became an icon of the
civil rights movement as she's often
credited as one of the first students to
integrate southern schools who is she
a a demon Collins the claudette colvin
see ruby bridges or de ella baker I'm
gonna go with C Ruby Bridges here's some
haters in the background yeah take mine
won't you tear my gosh it's definitely
between C and D all right I'm gonna go
with D Hattie Daniel you know what okay
all right I'll take it I will take it to
appear in a mainstream comic a black
lightning be storm see Black Panther or
DB Paige I'm gonna go see Black Panther
I'm not confident I don't know a lot
about comic books that's a guess yeah
III got it wrong so what did that
occurred that led to an estimated 6
million black Americans moving from the
rural areas of the south to more
populated centers in the north and west
a the great migration
to C or D the civil war again I'm going
to go with black player to play in the
majors Jackie Robinson final answer I
said you don't even want to hear two
options
wait
hey see moonlight I'm just gonna lose
the destiny it's okay the Negro
advancement in the Association of
colored people see the non-white
Association of the Advancement of
Colored People or deed the national
advancement for the Association of I'm
gonna go with a who was an LGBTQ rights
activists who held a prominent role in
the Stonewall uprising in late June 1969
that helped ignite the modern gay rights
movement be Marsha P Johnson saw
documentary on
that's Carly's like hope yeah I'm Carly
I have a question for you oh yeah
we're doing we're in the video you're my
phone a friend I need your black history
knowledge are you ready okay we're gonna
go with Bessie Coleman friend hope she
doesn't say anything to ethnic answer hi
you're on speakerphone you're on
speakerphone and you're on a video I'm
on a video we are doing black trivia you
are my phone a friend okay so here's the
question Jada what's the question we're
gonna go with Stevie you know don't ever
call me again I don't want ever talk to
use my number we're done being friends
okay thank you
I would like to thank the Academy and I
would like to thank my fellow black
friends here who didn't know as much as
I did thank you it was fun learn some
things today and if fun is relative you
know it was a game definitely didn't
learn most of these things from school
like at least at least I don't remember
and just from random just reading stuff
I'm learning that through these videos
to the people I interact with now or
just like through learning now but not
through school I definitely didn't learn
who the first black person to be a major
league was clearly I didn't they may
like only tell us I'm Jackie Robinson
because he broke like racial barriers we
learned a lot about like who invented
what or who was the first but I think
those are really important but it's
important to continue to talk about them
after February and also talk about I
mean I know it's 2020 but they're still
like the first black person to do stuff
so like they're really important to talk
about as well
[Music]